selena gomez is 30 flirty and thriving
[Music]
and with a new decade comes new clarity
on her love life with a source telling
e.t she's more open to love but dating
isn't her only focus right now it's nice
to have a little bit something to myself
yeah and the actress is doing just that
as she rings in her 30th birthday our
source says selena isn't dating anyone
specific right now and although she's
more open to love cell is very much
focused on herself and her work she's in
a very healthy place she is feeling
fantastic and very mentally physically
and emotionally healthy i'm ready to do
it you know i'm ready to go to the next
level and while we support selena dating
or not dating doing whatever makes her
happy there's at least one person trying
to get the inside scoop on her love life
her grandma
so how did you end it with that guy
yeah that sells nana interrupting her
makeup tutorial to get the t on what
sounds like a recent split
so how did you end it with that guy
i'll tell you in a second
and while nana may be all up in cell's
business when it comes to her love life
the actresses only murders in the
building co-stars steve martin and
martin short are steering clear are
these guys meddling in your real-life
romantic relationships are they trying
to set you up with anybody
no
no just just me you're protective
they're we're very protective of her but
but you know most of the people you know
are dead we don't know anyone under 50.
so it's not like say i want you to meet
selena
now if we take a look back selena's had
quite the dating history oh my goodness
back in the day she was romantically
linked to nick jonas taylor lautner zed
and the weeknd but cell's most famous
relationship to date justin bieber whom
she dated in 2010. what is his favorite
feature that you love about justin um
his eyes
the two dated on and off for years but
officially called it quits in 2018. last
month selena revealed their breakup and
the public attention surrounding it only
made her stronger it was actually
it was really hard but you know being on
the other side of it i have to be honest
it's it's actually
it's actually been
really good for me um
it allowed me to develop such a
character
where i don't tolerate any sort of
nonsense or
respect in any way
and i think i'm really proud of how i've
come out of it and now selena knows
exactly what she's looking for in a
partner our source says she wants
someone who's trustworthy respectful and
honest with themselves and others real
supportive accepting nice thoughtful
funny and someone that's not in it for
the fame or attention which she echoed
while speaking with e.t in june about
steve and martin who set a pretty solid
example i think in general my standards
for humor and gentlemen and just
uh professionals um have been you know
the bar's been lifted pretty high but
regardless of any romance we know cells
30s are going to be her best most
fulfilling decade yet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]